[Music]
all right this weekend boy huh time
flies a mark president Trump's first
year in office so to commemorate the
occasion we send Tommy Lehren to one of
the most liberal places in America West
Hollywood California to pass out red
make America great again hats and figure
out what the good people of California
really think of our commander-in-chief I
told you we were going to do this here
you go we're coming up on the one-year
anniversary of President Trump's
inauguration so I'm out here trying to
figure out what Californians think about
his first year I think everybody's
pretty pretty convinced that it was a
failure let's face it he's done an
amazing job he's done in one year he's
accomplished more than Obama did in
eight years I read vibes and I don't
like his vibe at all what does that say
says make America great again if I can
so we're out here asking folks in West
Hollywood how they feel about President
Trump's first year how would you
describe it in one word or one sentence
be it I think it's really great I kind
of back him up I mean some of the things
says we're not on Twitter I don't
necessarily agree with all the time
do you read his tweets yes I do you find
him funny I feel like it's funny because
he's saying whatever is on his mind but
he doing too much he's doing too much as
a president you need to just relax
Trump's have been unpredictable so you
don't really know what he's gonna say
the next day he could say something
tomorrow that you know just like blows
everything up what do you think of his
first year in office
you know I'm gonna pass on what do you
think about his first year Stella Stella
bringing gifts why not
I'm guessing you don't want to have okay
are you sure it's an official it's an
official collector's item whose policy
if you were to describe president
Trump's first year in one word or one
sentence what would it be effective I
love it
we're just out here in West Hollywood
asking folks how they feel about
president Trump's first year what do you
feel about it yeah it's been rough for
everybody but I think that we should
come together as a country and support
whoever we have an office what do you
think of the first year I think first
year is absolutely phenomenal and I
think three more are gonna be over the
top what about a tax cut for 80% of
Americans what a tax cut for 80% of a
marital pays Isis that's all yeah well
thank you for your opinion
free speech did you want a hat sir the
voice of the generation was that guy
auntie feh
Tommy Lehren choice it's us was he with
that he wasn't stable what's that he
wasn't too stable
he wasn't stable I don't know if he was
an official antifoam member but he was
not stable but he had some very strong
opinions that he certainly shared with
me he didn't want a hat sadly maybe next
time we go back we can try to find him
again I think he's probably regretting
that decision they're great hats all
right I'd give you a lot of credit you
go out right in the middle here's the
interesting part to me this is what
Hollywood this is pretty liberal
California we're talking about a lot of
people like the president and we're like
yeah I like this guy yeah I like his
honesty I like he did warm one year than
Obama did in eight years I didn't expect
it
I was shocked shocked I've been there a
few times as you know but actually
asking folks how they felt about it and
they weren't just your typical people
that the left would say are Trump
supporters the diversity was astounding
that is the best kept secret in Los
Angeles California is how many
conservatives there are and how diverse
Trump supporters are conservatives are
Republicans are that's what the left
does not want you to know is how diverse
we are and I love it no I keep saying I
don't know if you agree with me or not
that Trump polls there's a certain group
of people that are just not going to
admit but they really like Trump they
like his outspokenness they like that
he's an iconic class and they also like
the economy and they like results and
all the noise isn't going to matter at
the end of the day if people get jobs in
the back at work and off of food stamps
and and and back in the labor force and
not in poverty even the ones that said
he did a horrible job when I stood there
a little bit longer and sort of
discussing it with him they really
couldn't give me any examples of how
he's done a horrible job they just again
they point to his tweets and how his
tweets hurt their feelings but when I
actually brought up some of the examples
like we went over last week about the
incredible improvements this president
is making to this country for all
Americans they seem to kind of
with me but again they had to bring back
in the fillings and they didn't like him
because you know he tweets this guy with
the Matt we send in enough security out
with you you you're okay the security is
excellent they're actually doing a very
good job and the nice thing about it is
we were able to calm him down enough to
have him explain himself as you can see
his language was colorful but at the end
of the day I think maybe we reformed him
just a little bit I think he walked away
pretty excited about Fox News all right
really excited great work
Tommy Lehren we'll see you later in the
week thank you as always for doing that
for us we